so here's what we gonna do you can
actually see what I've got for you is
this is actually these are the same
graph I'm not telling you what the
equation of the graph is partly because
that's sort of the point you don't need
to know what the equation is to still do
what we're about to do okay now I didn't
print it on there but you can see it on
the screen can you help me label so this
parabola here we're going to call that f
of X okay so if if this curve is
presented to you and said hey here's a
function and now can you tell me what
this related function looks like y
equals F of 2x minus 6 how do we get
from this this original graph to 2 what
this guy looks like okay so there's um
there's these two numbers here the 2 and
the minus 6 and we want to know what
they do okay so what I'm gonna ask you
to do is and maybe if you use your red I
think that's probably best way to go so
each of these numbers does something
different okay now the two that's
attached to the X when you see you're
multiplying something and we call that a
dilation so what this does is it's going
to make things stretched out or
compressed so generally speaking if I
gave you an f of X and then I said hey
can you tell me what f of say X on to
looks like okay what it would look like
is the same graph but it's been dilated
or stretched out it's it's twice as wide
so it looks like it's gained some weight
okay and it's wide because what's being
changed here is the X and X is
horizontal that make sense so if by
contrast like say that was was it like
that so I put a y equals over here this
guy is twice as wide now if I said
instead of X onto if I said Y on to okay
again this is another dilation because
it's it's a multiplication or division
but it's not gonna be wider because I'm
not changing X anymore I'm changing Y so
instead of being bigger this way yeah
you're gonna stretch vertically exactly
right so this I guess you'd say
twice as tall right so this is what
happens when you make things bigger or
if if you're doing it vertically if you
do it
horizontally now if you have a look over
here what I've got here is not X divided
by two I have X lots of five by two yeah
so you know how I said that these ones
over on the right-hand side they make
things taller or wider yeah this is
gonna get squashed in so it's gonna get
compressed so because it's a two there
I'm gonna say this is sort of yeah
compressed it's everything that used to
take up this amount of space is now
taking up half that space yeah okay
which is a bit weird it reversed okay
but um yeah I think that's that's an
okay thing to say so let's write in that
this is going to be it's gonna be half
the width I guess there's a way to say
it can you remind me as well how did I
know that its width and not height
that's being changed very good yeah yeah
exactly so you can see the change is
happening on this printing rule not the
other one okay very good
okay very so I've got that and then I've
got to do is minus six so um this is not
a dilation this is what we call a
translation yeah exactly so we actually
met this word all the way back in new so
there's a long time ago it's out taking
the shape and then like the synonym we
used to use was we slide it around or we
shift it around okay
so once we've worked out how big it is
we then say okay what position is it in
okay now there's kind of a sneaky thing
here and we've got let's actually use
the space underneath the graph because
we've got some space down there you've
been given y equals F of 2x minus six
like so and we said oh okay it's gonna
be half the width so we will work out
what that looks like in a second but
that minus six
it's it sort of seems like okay you're
gonna move 6 units right but you're not
which is very sneaky right underneath
this on the next line that minus six is
not actually I'm acting directly on the
X I want you to imagine kind of like
have you ever seen like a rugby union
right and the ball the ball goes on the
ground and then they all getting this
big pile big scrum right and they're all
trying to push the ball back and forth
okay now there's some people who are
really close to where the ball is and
they're pushing directly on the other
team okay and then you've got like
people all the way at the back and
they're pushing as well but they're
pushing is kind of indirect right
they're pushing people who are pushing
people who are trying to act on this
right so the further back you are it's
like ah like they have less of an impact
as it were yeah - six if you like it's
kind of further away from the X so what
we should really write is a
factorization here it's really two
outside of X minus three so can you see
now that minus three is actually
directly acting on X is no two in the
way okay so you know how we we said okay
the two means it's half the width we
already wrote that down up above but now
let's put together now we know that the
translation is not gonna be six unit
it's gonna be three
okay we also know it's horizontal
because it's changing the X but I'm
gonna ask you is it left or is it right
what do you think so it's okay good
instinct right now the way I remember
like which one it is is um if you know
you don't have to write this down but if
you know what this looks like
Mike was x squared do you have a picture
in your head of what that probably looks
like so it's concave up it's got it's a
little the vertex that's part of the
bottom it's at the origin okay now if I
compare that to something like let's do
this right what would that look like
okay now I am gonna draw it for you you
don't have to but the original graph
looks like this X minus 3 all squared
it's different because there's a
horizontal translation where's the new
intercept like it's not gonna be here at
0 0 where's it gonna be I think I need
to think about what value of x sorry
it's on the wrong spot what value of x2
I put in ah yeah it's a positive 3 right
so I would go oh it's over there and
then I draw the rest of the shape so you
can clearly see that has moved to the
right exactly like what you said
this guy will as well so everything is
kind of backwards you're like ah this
multiplying by two doesn't make you
twice as big it makes you half and this
minus three doesn't leave you to the
left move to the right so everything is
kind of weird and reverse so three units
right would I guess is the way out so
well upward downward left hood right
with okay right so we're going to do
these two changes okay we've got this
graph I know the two things we need to
do we've got to do a dilation we've got
to do a translation okay there's one
last question which is which one do you
do first okay because if you think about
your order of operations if you do
operations in different order you get
different answers right yeah exactly
like if let's just um think about a
numerical example here right if I said
to you can you please tell me what is
five times three take away one right now
you have two operations there yeah and
depending on which one you do first you
get completed for airtime right
we know what the order of operations are
we're like oh you multiply first yeah
right and then you do your subtraction
okay I hope you can see here though if I
did it in the wrong order
it just completely goes yeah he's very
confusing right you're like oh if I do
my subtraction first get five times two
and that's 10 you're like what which one
is it okay so we have to work out which
one is first yeah
thankfully for us the order of
operations with numbers is exactly the
same as the order operations with graphs
so which one which should we do first we
do half the width first okay so let's go
let's have a look now this is the graph
and what we do the easiest way to do
this is and whichever color you want is
fine when they provide it to you if they
don't give you an equation like told you
this is y equals x squared whatever they
have to give you grid lines like I have
presented to you because you've got to
work out points on the graph and then
use those points to help you so I want
you to look and tell me which parts of
the graph can you see lie on like some
nice neat coordinates can you see any of
it are easy to point out
well you can you could give me a
stationary point if you like I'm really
looking for things that line up on grid
lines because then I know what numbers
they are and then I can do this having
and translating all the rest so pick any
point you like yes fantastic so I've got
two intercepts very good so the
intercepts are at 0 and 4 so let's just
start with those it's your own fault
okay and we will definitely you're using
blue so I'll use blue as well okay so
silly silly question to ask but it's not
rhetorical I'm having the width of this
right so the x value for this first
intercept here is 0 what's half of 0 0
so I'm going to put an X right there
okay that point when i when i dilate it
doesn't go anywhere
yeah now when it goes to the other
intercept you like oh it's 4 so I'm
having everything right so what is it
now
it'll be interesting it - very good
ok so I'll put an X there um find me
some other points what's another point
on the graph like you got your
intercepts grade are there any other
points that you can see line up nicely
yeah the top of the curve the vertex
right so we would say it's x coordinate
is 2 so I'm gonna have that and I'm
going to make it 1 very good and you can
sort of continue this process right I'm
gonna pause for a minute and let you
find as many nicely aligned spots and
then see where they actually should go
to when you have them ok have a think
what other ones do you see there's one
quite close to that vertex so you can
see that right quite close to the top a
couple actually yes you've got um this x
value here is one yeah and then you've
also got parameters of symmetrical yeah
so if you've got one of the left yeah
you can see it on the other side so what
x value is that one on the right hand
side that's three very good so we want
to have both of those so the first one
is one it's gonna have to be ha ha very
good
1/2 of one is half good umm and then 1/2
of three
one half cool and now just before we go
any further because we're sort of
getting to the point where we've got a
good picture here um you can see you're
like oh the parabola I had before you
starting can you see where the blue dots
are gonna line up you're like oh I have
another parabola but it's just skinnier
which is kind of what I wanted right
when I'm half the width I gave you quite
a lot of vertical scale here can you see
one other spot which also has this
mirror yeah very good so what's that x
value over there
yeah negative one so what's half the
width very good and then this yeah
there's the symmetrical version so
that's x equals what five so you have it
you get x equals very good okay so it
looks to me at least when I design this
I think that's all other points that sit
nicely okay
so what I'm gonna do is I'm gonna think
about okay what does this thing look
like I'm not this is not the actual
graph then I'm gonna end up with because
I only done one of the transformations
I've only done the squashing fit yeah I
need to do the second one but let's just
quickly get a sense for ourselves I'm
just going to draw some dotted lines
here I'm like ah if I join the knots if
I connect these right here is this sort
of skinnier looking parabola that we
were hoping to get so you're like okay
good I've done one of my translations
and I guess it sort of keeps on going
downwards like that
okay okay fantastic so we used blue why
don't we switch over to red okay we have
done the check it out we've done half
the width okay and now we've got to do
the other trans transformation which is
three units to the right which in some
ways is even easier than what we did
just the arc is like our just everything
yeah just move it right so it makes
sense to take those same what do we how
many do yet we had five points yeah five
points and to remove all of them three
units okay so let's just go from left to
right that first one you can see there
on the left it's at negative 1/2 so you
add three yeah it missed a two and a
half that's interesting so I'm actually
going to you don't have to put this on
yours but I'm gonna show in this other
color I'm moving that guy to the right
okay instead of using an X because
want to confuse the stuff here I guess I
put a big fat dot in in red okay all
right let's keep on going from left to
right so I've got that um that theme of
the origin right so it moves also three
units everything Esther yep it's going
to be moved over to three you're gonna
keep going right you tell me what to do
next
yep it was a wanna know it's at 4-4 good
the next boy yep the next blue point
yeah from one and a half to four and a
half you sort of getting the hang of
this right in fact you can kind of see
the shape itself just sort of following
the pattern that you've already
established so what's the last one the
last one was at two and a half so it
becomes five and a half okay so now
we've got our red points and just like
before we're gonna join them and this
time because this is our final answer
let's do a nice thick line all the way
through it so I'm gonna go and it's
quite hard to make sure you get through
like sort of thread the needle perfectly
so take your time when i when i'm doing
this on paper or that was terrible sorry
i'm gonna try to fix that when i do some
paper I often do my first graph in
pencil because it's like if you screw it
up it's easy to fix
and but then your final answer has to be
in pair of some kind especially at the
HSC they scan everything and pencil
doesn't show up very well um guess what
you're done that is y equals F of 2x
minus 6 okay nicely done
okay great effort so let's just let's
just make sure remember okay go back to
the start um what did we do we had to
think carefully about like one of these
one of these numbers actually do exactly
precisely and there was a sneaky thing
in that the way it's written it's not
ready to graph yeah you have to
factorize um and that's a very common
thing because then your order of
operations becomes a bit more obvious
and also like it's a very common mistake
the students will translate it
six units to the right not three so just
have to have that